Steve Reed for the opposition is with us
this morning good morning good morning
what happens we're just talking there
about in the fact that he's lied
previously in fact twice previously for
lying what happens if he lies to the
committee and he's subsequently found to
have lied well perhaps that's what he's
doing with the submission that he's put
in but we're talking about a man here
who has absolutely no regard for
standards in public life and no regard
for the truth he's TR you know he's he's
claimed for years now that he hadn't
misled Parliament and then yesterday he
finally admits that he did mislead
Parliament but he didn't know he's not
responsible for what he did now you will
remember I did apologize for that in the
May of the following year but but you'll
remember as I do those that video where
we had his the prime minister's then
prime minister's press spokesperson
Allegra Stratton standing at a Podium
laughing about the fact that they'd been
at a lockdown breaking party and number
10 the night before Boris Johnson Boris
Johnson knew it was well Boris Johnson
stood up in the House of Commons the
next morning and said he shared the name
shock and then we found out he'd
actually been at the party now somebody
who was at a party doesn't need to be
told they were at a party they know they
were hundreds of people work at dining
Street and it's a very small townhouse
and they're all crammed in there and
you're walking past people all the time
I think when you're wheeling in
suitcases full of boobs music systems he
was at the party you know these the lies
this is the man who set the rules he
wrote the rules that the country had to
abide obligators through a pandemic the
reason that people are so Furious is
because the British public followed
those rules to keep everybody else Safe
People missed going to their loved ones
funerals people died on their own but
the Prime Minister who wrote the rules
who understood the rules was breaking
the rules now he's been called to
account what I hope will happen as a
result of what we're seeing with this
committee which remember has a
conservative majority on it is that
Boris Johnson will finally accept
responsibility for once for his behavior
and for the truth in this circumstance
they also has a labor chair and Peter
bone was that where you were in the last
hour and he said she's biased it has a
labor chair but it has a conservative
majority nothing on it can happen
without the majority voting voting for
it so we'll see what recommendations the
committee makes it will then come back
to the Chamber of the House of Commons
and I I expect we will have a vote on
the sanction that is recommended now I
hope that Rishi sunak will finally stand
up to his former boss that we won't see
any repeat of where they tried to change
the rules for Owen Patterson leading to
the crisis that contributed to Boris
Johnson's downfall in the first place if
the if the government doesn't stand up
for standards in public life who on
Earth will no standards in public life
it just so happens that I've been
reading my telegraph this morning and
your boss appears to be an absolute
hypocrite when it comes to pensions well
I don't think that's a fair a fair thing
why not a talk okay well we nearly call
me I very nearly did I do know the
difference the the it wasn't kyostarma
as director of public prosecutions who
set his own pension that was set by the
conservative government at the time so
if people have problems problems with it
they really need to speak to David
Cameron and George he changed the rules
it was it was for them when he's Prime
well the the point is this isn't really
about Kia and in any case exactly the
contributions the contributions that
care made to his pension never reach the
cap in any case so those Provisions so
so those Provisions don't apply what
happened last week was we had Jeremy
Hunt uh announcing a budget in which he
increased taxes on working people by
freezing the tax thresholds it's a form
of stealth tax he increased taxes on
working people to the highest they've
been for 70 years and yet he felt that
was an appropriate time to give the top
one percent of earners a billion pound
tax in order to help doctors come back
to work which is what you guys wanted to
do was treating the shadow Health
secretary said that was a great idea it
is a great idea to help doctors but why
is he helping everyone else more than
doctors as well Hive off doctors is what
we're told anyway
if he becomes prime minister so that
directors of public prosecutions both
now and previously do not get this well
the the rules that those those schemes
were put in place so that we didn't have
an exodus of judges and you know that
we've got you know the biggest backlog
on record of Trials if we change the
pension scheme for judges and those
judges then what is already a 60 000
backlog in the crown courts three-year
delays okay for judges it's okay for uh
leaders of the director of public
prosecutions it's okay for doctors
um okay for everybody
I mean how do you where do you draw the
line if you don't do it for doctors then
we'll see more doctors leaving the
Health Service and we've already got
seven million people on the waiting list
so I think there is a case there is a
case for doctors what Jeremy Hunt didn't
need to do was raise stealth taxes on
working people to the highest that
they've been for 70 years at a time when
inflation we've got those figures today
out of control highest in the G7
people's wages are being held down
prices are going up in the shops and
Jeremy Hunt gave people the highest tax
rate for 70 years change the rules as
far as the Director of public
prosecution's final salary and pension
is concerned if he is prime minister
what labor has said yes we support the
specifics for judges and for doctors and
what about everyone else or the DPP is
in there with the judges okay so that's
why it was done so he will still be
allowed to have his well the scheme was
done oh my goodness may you can see how
that could be hypocritical for a lot of
people but it isn't if people have got a
concern about Kia's pension talk to
David Cameron and George Osborne Osborne
who put it in place
and you'll say you wouldn't change the
rules it's part of the judge's scheme
and Labor's got no plan to change judges
pension Arrangements because you'd lose
judges and then the delays in the courts
would get worse the key Point here is
the vast majority of the population have
just had a massive tax hike or the top
one percent got a giveaway why is that
the priority that the conservatives have
chosen at this time